[Musik]
viel spaß wie hin und weg wünscht ihnen
weltkrieg und oder andere land habe so
schwierig dass es wird die ganze welt
frage wird lager das ist ja genau schön
etwas liebe kaleem italienische
verrücktheit zu machen
[Musik]
zg
islam
[Musik]
die kerle
berlin
[Musik]
zuletzt
bienvenido ich bin unterwegs mexiko knox
monterey den schweizer denis und sind an
mexikanische frau den 1 und für mich
gesetzt die mexikanischen 4000
[Musik]
[Applaus]
unterstehen
man weiß ja nie was mit dem scharfen
schnitt nur das klischee aber so stimmt
einiges nicht am bild von mexiko wo man
als schweizer soll nach dem es ist
sommer von gegangen zu einem zeitpunkt
wenn es not ich bin kann
speedy gonzales kontakte laufen mit dem
song bringen und einen bundschuh 24
stunden und auch eine polizistin aus und
viele mexikaner dörfer kennenlernen und
auch mit mexiko mit der
staatsanwaltschaft ob hubers wenig
kräfte sind so lebensfrohe menschen so
glücklich ich würde mich wo der kultura
steckt dass ich jetzt über sechs jahre
wählen situation bezüglich der blonde
[Musik]
das ist ja wie ist es in der schweiz
empfindest du es gleich
also ich das erste mal in der schweiz
war fühlte ich mich sehr allein
niemand hat mich begrüßt niemand nahm
ich war ich fühlte mich allein und habe
geprägt die vorstellung ich würde
[Applaus]
[Musik]
mexiko
anfangs habe ich oft mit dem gestritten
sogar zu oft ich habe schon das gehört
für mich zwingend zum leben dazu teilen
ist alles die finanzwelt liegen wo die
moosburger rentiert das unbedingt
doch unter druck
[Musik]
darum hat mit andere teile bauer sagt
für die nächsten ihren das leben
einziehen der emilia ganz konkret
zweimal in der woche treffen sie für
über 200 bedürftige und obdachlose von
monterey als richtiges familie projekt
alpha mit
wir dachten wenn wir den anderen helfen
geht es ihnen besser
aber in wirklichkeit geht es uns besser
wenn die anderen helfen
[Musik]
die niederlage geht
monterey liegt im norden von mexiko zwei
stunden vor der amerikanische grenzen
weg statt mit über vier millionen liegen
finanziell ganz der familie fand
jedenfalls könnte
mit herzlichem tod von eric brüder von
denen sich inzwischen tradition wurde
oder ganze familie beim verarbeiten von
einem schweren schicksalsschlag hilft
und das ist es warum es grad ist nach
gibt als sich sogar bei der polizei
gesprochen
[Musik]
es ist eine schöne friedliche atmosphäre
da und ist eine fülle der sonnenweg
balsam ist für ziel voran
es ist nicht so dass das kleine zuhörer
wollten ist zum idioten oder also die
hand sie haben sie verliert wenn sie
jetzt knie verletzt und einen vorschlag
macht somit schweiz und dann hätte ich
ja wer soll den schweizer werkplatz
freundin als als als mit den katalog ist
relativ einfach sitzung zu sega mullahs
der charakterzug der charakter suchend
dass das haben wir ja so zweimal
schneller und das ist gut so
[Musik]
chrysler ist macht platz für besucher
der lama ihre mutter anastasia und der
ukraine
es gibt hier nur gut wenn politik tag
her hier
ich möchte sie so gerne in den arm
nehmen sie ist ein bisschen kleiner als
ich und ich mag ihren geruch in meiner
nase
sie ist jetzt schon 72 und noch sehr
selbstständig in meiner familie ist sie
der general plant ist anastasia 4 wheel
die schweiz blieb das hat natürlich
auswirkungen aufs ganze familie lebe was
mich wahnsinnig viel gesehen und wenn
man sagen denn ich sehe vielleicht das 1
1 konnten ihr interesse
ballack sind klar die der hochaltar der
immer dort lebt
aber dass ich überhaupt kein problem
will ich bin ein relativ beschäftigt da
auch immer wieder weggezogen und
mehreren jahren und wahnsinnig romina
kommunizieren will klären lassen ob
juristisch ist das wenig aber meine
morgenarbeit geblieben bei
schwiegermonster überhaupt nicht
[Musik]
anna und ihre mutter jeden tag per skype
miteinander in kontakt aber sich endlich
wieder richtig
das ist noch mal ganz anders
na na
[Musik]
anastasia ich zum sechsten mal in der
schweiz als erstes highlight wünscht
sich jeweils fisch im
flughafenrestaurant ist alles
reibungslos abgelaufen es heiko striegel
deine psyche
[Musik]
ich freue mich jetzt drei monate hier
sein zu können
aber wir müssen uns ein bisschen
zusammenreißen
wir werden uns mühe geben müssen wir
haben das vorher besprochen und
abgemacht dass wir uns mit unserem
charakter und den emotionen
zurückhaltend
zwei frauen in einer küche das kann
schwierig werden
nein alles wird gut mama gib mir deine
hand
ich bin ja schon älter und brauchen
einfach etwas aufmerksamkeit
ja ich habe schon mit martin gesprochen
wir haben jetzt nicht nur einen sondern
eine tochter um die wir uns kümmern
müssen
eine oma
[Musik]
nun gut vielleicht alles okay auto kam
alles gut
ok ich super
[Musik]
ich liebe seine ruhige und intelligente
seite ich finde seine intelligenz sexy
[Musik]
es ist das buch herr thomas kleibl das
letzte mal vor mitternacht und schweizer
fernsehen aber gestiegen und so sima
david fdp kritisch der thomas ist immer
noch rar die erstarrten den
französischen teil programm aber zu
entdecken da am deutsche weihnachtsmarkt
heime letzte spitze
je nach zwischen verschiedensten dinge
zu merken
also strom strom
dass die landschaft hier liege
aber da darf man auf die straße gehen
können
nach
[Musik]
hat nicht angefangen zu essen
erste thomas dort genau mitmachen steht
noch nicht fest
er muss sich zuerst einmal neu
orientieren schließlich hat er gerade
erst für sind beruf sind die familie
freunde und das land zurück glauben
zum spaziergang führte pause im sutil im
café wo von davids in der familie
betrieben wird
da wirtschaft im moment eher manager
vieh und die straße der ganze betrieb
auf nachhaltigkeit und stelle
vielleicht ist thomas daum bald nicht
nur nach und karriere machen und dafür
muss ich mit herz
für thomas nach zwei studien
abgeschlossen
kelly und umweltwissenschaften mit einem
rucksack sind die sau kamera
interessante perspektive der eigentlich
aus russland 5 gewann mit 53 zu 47 es
hat wenig neue user fordere gefährde
gebucht wo keiner was die katholiken
neues kreiert neues probieren man ist so
dass man sich dazu einfach ausschneiden
zwar bereiten gibt und dann mit der
ausstellung will ich plötzlich und mit
kulig oder besser darf was er hole ich
mir vorgestellt habe eigentlich zu den
zwar zu 81 prozent sinkt
mega glücklich dass ein schweizer wo sie
in der profactor war die schweiz noch
mexikos und seine mix chris cools ich
fühle mich da die haare und make-up den
mexikanern fühlt sich angesteckt
die erlaubnis photonics kommen die
entwickelt sowie das eigene mexiko noch
mal neu durch das schwitzen
[Musik]
mexiko erschüttert oder blues
allerseelen
wir sind auf dem weg warum er sie los
ist die einzige
danach blieb er ist es also not oder so
noch nach einer besinnlichen aber dass
alle unbedingt darüber also ich da ganz
mexiko der ruf der vögel ist immer
wieder schön muss das so halb leer ist
megaschön aber detailliert zeigt auf dem
programm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der tote gedenke die anteilsscheine von
der wichtigsten 4 ticks mexiko und
danken trickfilm coco kennt die ganze
welt jetzt das fest für mut noch hat
sauber gedeihen so viele touristen
[Applaus]
auf die suche nach einer besinnlichen fx
im oktober von mexiko plant
und natürlich und nein sie unter dem
hieß aus echte influenza versuch mit
wieder stoff will wenn er darauf hin so
farbige und verrückt die bilder in szene
und fans trifft auf die straße
belohnte truppe vom berühmte platz
carolin reese und gavin andere kleinere
friedhof da sind instagram oder youtube
nun wichtig da denkt man sie nur noch
ihren bruder eric womit nun seien
gestorben ist und wie sie das grab wir
schmücken
juni geschafft zum día de los muertos 4
der in riga sind immer noch 2
[Musik]
reagieren sie nicht gedacht
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
- drew brees graz gewinner von montana
ist gnadenlos will man mal sogar der
strom ausfällt ist es für
überlebenswichtig und sind sich das
gewöhnt sind acht jahren bis jetzt schon
einmal dort mit dem trainer
außer dass das jetzt aber wenn du andere
blues stars gesucht und du musst keine
briefe stone age of american bis also
das durch damit zur herrscher des
stammes hatte ich darf es keine alte
vater jan als wahlfach mit alten vater
offiziell sinne ist
ich brauchte einfach aber eher aus wie
sie das macht und am anfang bin ich sehr
wichtig schließlich sowie aggressiven
charakter und ich habe wirklich mut
machen und bin ich so wie das internet
ist persönlichen hass und einfach nicht
das kann ich natürlich verbessern damit
umgeht zurückziehen wenn er mehr akzente
ried hat vieles dazugelernt sieht sie
mit dem jay verortet ist englisch ist
schwierig sie meistens aber hat sich die
zwei schnellen kunden besonders wenn es
um der indianische hintergrund von
gegangen ist mit dem hat sich sofort
identifizieren
das ist der neue schild den sie für mich
gemacht hat früher hätte man das mit die
kamera überzogener um feiler abzuhalten
heutzutage ist das bloße dekoration ob
sie es über ziehen solle aber ich fand
es nicht
wir haben viele komplimente gekriegt das
online stellte
verständlich gehöre die entsprechen die
acht original richtig und zweifach desto
besser
sieben stunden fahrt 1 vor sich genau
wie die familie zum ersten mal die
emotionen vor
[Musik]
also ja natürlich
auf der internetsite text eben jetzt
besonders forum kam wurden also experte
wodurch schon viel über die ukrainische
und russische frauen einig so oder so
und das ist drin so mehrheitlich haben
so dass die frau damit sie wirksam us
industrie zu frauen war die deutsche
frau dass frau in mitteleuropa er damit
seiner karriere anstreben und die frau
hat in der ukraine dass die bereits in
zum 27
[Musik]
in meiner liebe immer ich nur ich
mehr
es ist kurz vor weihnachten dolana ihrem
motor ist schon seit drei wochen zu
besuch und immer noch sind die beide ein
herz und eine seele
wenigstens meistens ich hatte mir
anfangs sorgen gemacht ist unsere
unterschiedlichen charaktere erneut
aufeinander prallen könnten wir sind
halt wie wildschweine
wir sind beide im jahr der schweiz
geboren mutter ist ein leittier und ich
bin ein leibchen und wir sehen nicht
nach aber gilt für mehr frieden
geschlossen
[Musik]
klassische super jungs was ihr könnt das
nicht da wirklich nicht genial und sehr
schönsten hier schnell da wo ok nach
[Musik]
teil
nämlich dass im blick
[Gelächter]
mit großmutter auf dass leoni passt
könnte lana und der martin endlich
wieder mal bis 200 ich bin sehr
glücklich dass wir mal zeit nur für uns
gefunden haben
hier auf dem eis ohne schüler und ohne
unseren sohn
sonst sehe das so alles wie bei denen
aber so kann ich mich wieder mal wie ein
kleines mädchen für und nicht wie eine
ratte tante
war der moment als bauer vom ist
launisch
obwohl sie ihre sorgfalt zur richtigen
schluss kunde die schweiz hat lehrerin
musst du keinen honig dass ich bewundere
ich freue mich dass er macht einfach ein
altes landgut alles hinter merlot und
neu anfangen und dem treppenhaus sie
muss zurück steht gar gelistet sie hätte
eine frage der ehre gottes billig und
kandidaten setzen willst dahinter kann
tisch und muss die pläne herrschte und
und muss auch über liebe und die macher
darüber dass sich die freunde wirklich
wo bzw
naja
[Musik]
für mich war es ein segen ihn
kennengelernt zu haben
er hat mir eine neue welt eröffnet
meinen kleinen sozialen kreis gesprengt
alles woran ich glaubte dies kam und
sagte schau mal das alles gibt es
ich war gott sehr dankbar alles was ich
mir gewünscht habe traf ein
ich war sehr verliebt und jetzt kann ich
meinen weg gehen und er seinen denn wir
sind bald frei
darf ich selten ruß von den nc da wohnt
sitzt mit dem denise manns nicht gerade
irgendwo mitten auf reisen sind
roller ist nahm sie ihre große
leidenschaft mittlerweile verdient sein
geld mit ihrer kunst
[Musik]
ich mach mit dem demis ein spaziergang
durchs quartier im gegensatz zu sp
andere gegen die stadt haben sich da
relativ gut frei bewegen
das ist ein großer unterschied waren
wurde von mexiko wo du so nicht hat die
grenze bis zu der usa oder dem süden wie
schwer sie das schlaflied mit offenen
die oscars gibt es historisches ist
unsicher
ja im notfall schaute werk wo halt die
konstrukteurs um als zwei stunden von
der grenze entfernt ok also ich da ein
größerer interessenskonflikt oder karte
und wurde für die migration
wurde dem historischen bild de für ihn
und meint sie aufgefangen husum blau mit
der baubewilligung ist macht es sehr
romantisch zusammen am boden schlafen
das ist die definition von immer noch
sehr verliebt sein
[Gelächter]
fühlst du dich hier zu hause
ja ich bin gerne hier
highlight kann mir aber auch ein leben
anders vorstellen
ich spüre meine eltern sind nun dafür
bereit
der nächste schritt ist dass wir eine
wohnung mieten ja ich fühle mich bereit
möchten deine eltern
ich kann sicher
wir sind für fünf stunden dann ist das
schloss was ich geschlafen
[Musik]
hektisch mit ständig wieder familie
gottes
[Musik]
mit einem feinen essen wo werde ich euch
in fünf jahren treffen
ich würde gern in mexiko bleiben aber um
kinder mit einem haus zu haben will mir
der süden von mexiko liebe zwischen
europa
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so beck ist neue die high vom thomas
kleiber ehemalige kinderzimmer von sima
david sie trotz kanadas schritte thomas
block
der punkt kommt und setzte so einfach
sachlich mit dem autor zähler mein leben
und meine ich kann nicht anders und
sachen blunt und liebt und was sie so
erlebt und ich denke es sollte sorry zur
alleine sitzen informativ sie und zu
erlauben dass sie lustig sie das will
bz ernst ist die mannschaft der wahl und
das andere ist dass sich einfach
schweizer oder das dach jetzt mache
strehmel lang mit was sollten sie nötig
ist sage ich mich ganz allein geschafft
hat bis gemacht und was zählte druck und
da merkt dass man das sehr verinnerlicht
hat dass man immer im bismarck osterburg
einfach aufhören
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der heutigen stadt und er ist für die
zukunft und was bringt
[Musik]
unter martin und lana planen muss
merkste kritik sind wir wieder hin
[Musik]
juni
hin und weg ist ihnen präsentiert wurde
frau dr oetker